european ministers responsible for
employment and social affairs meeting in
brussels will discuss new rules to
better protect workers who are
temporarily posted abroad by their
employers the idea is to ensure certain
minimum terms and conditions of
employment on issues like working hours
minimum wage health and safety
provisions and equal opportunities as
well as to halt social dumping
the council will also take stock of the
progress on a directive that aims to
break the glass ceiling that continues
to bar female talent from top positions
in europe's biggest companies
the new rules would oblige companies
listed on stock exchanges in the eu to
bring in transparent recruitment
procedures
so that by twenty twenty at least forty
percent of their non-executive directors
are women
ministers will also take stock of how
the youth guarantee and the youth
employment initiatives are being
implemented in the member states these
aim to give young people a better chance
to enter the labour market
health and consumer affairs ministers
will exchange views on draft new rules
on medical devices such as x-ray
machines heart valves or breast implants
with the idea to better protect patients
and dissuade fraud
ministers will also review the state of
play in the negotiations on future eu
tobacco rules which aim at making
tobacco products less attractive the
plan is to come to an agreement before
the end of the year but the split over
how to regulate e-cigarettes is not yet
over